[MUSIC PLAYING]
GREG GARRETT: Thank you.
Thank you so much.
How is everyone today?
AUDIENCE: Pretty good.
GREG GARRETT: Brilliant.
I bring greetings from
Austin, the live music
capital of the world.
I had to get a
special dispensation
to come without a guitar today.
Otherwise you are penalized
when you come back,
and you have to sort of
walk the walk of shame
down Congress Avenue.
And I bring greetings
also from Paris,
where I'm serving this summer
as the theologian in residence
at the American
Cathedral in Paris,
and I am living in a bell
tower like Quasimodo.
It's 64 steps up, and
I blew my knee out
two years ago in this
apartment, and it is not
getting any better, but it
is a joy to be with you today
and to talk about this new book
from Oxford University Press,
"Living With the Living Dead."
And I'm going to read you
a tiny little piece of it,
and then I'm going to talk
about some of the things
that sort of impelled me
to write it, because one
of the things that I want
to confess sort of straight
off the bat is that
I don't sit around
at night watching zombie films.
That is not necessarily
my entertainment du jour.
And one of the things
that I discovered is--
I talked with people
about this book
over the last couple of years
that I was working on it--
was that there were two really
sort of radically different
responses to the
fact that I was going
to make this my
25th or 26th book,
and it was going to
be about zombies.
And so there were
some people who were
like, why would you do that?
What a waste of gray matter?
Find something else.
Write another novel.
Do this.
Do that.
And I noticed, by
the way, that there
tended to be sort of
a generational aspect
to this breakdown.
So a couple of weeks ago
in San Antonio, Texas, I
was giving a talk about the
book, and one of the questions
was basically, can
you tell me why
my grandchildren want to get
on the TV and kill zombies?
And when I could actually
explain that to them,
they were like, oh, that
kind of makes sense.
So you've got your
one group, who's
like, I don't understand
this whole thing.
I get that it's a thing.
And then you've got
the other group,
and when I told
them I was working
on a book on the zombie
apocalypse, they were like, oh,
sweet.
Cannot wait.
And so really very
different responses,
but what it encouraged me to
think about is that I actually
needed to write a book that
helped both of those sets
of people understand why it is
that the zombie apocalypse is
such a powerful and pervasive
story in our kind of post-9/11
Western environment.
And so to start off with, I
think it's probably important
to recognize that, even if
you are not a connoisseur
of zombies, you
cannot avoid them.
This, of course, is last
week's "New Statesman,"
and, as much as I admire
the "New Statesman"
as a middle aged, white,
liberal leaning sort of person,
it's not hip.
And one of the things that's
been really interesting, as I
thought about the
sort of pervasiveness,
the reach of the story
of the zombie apocalypse,
is that, even
though it starts out
in what we might think
of as geek culture
and with teenagers
and 20-somethings,
it has spread out from there
to an incredible extent.
In my research,
what I discovered
is that, in addition to
last week's "New Statesman,"
we often find images
from or references
to the zombie apocalypse
and "The Financial Times,"
in "The Economist,"
in the venerable
"New York Times,"
which a couple of years
ago recorded that, in the
entire history of "The New York
Times," they had used the words
zombie apocalypse four times,
but in the most recent year
they had used it 20 times,
including in a story on peanut
butter and banana sandwiches.
And so when we take that,
when we take the zombie films,
novels, comics, when we take the
fact that "The Walking Dead" is
the most popular television show
in the world in the 19 to 49
demographic, when we take the
fact that "Game of Thrones"
is one of the world's most
popular, most watched, most
stolen shows--
and if you forget for a
moment that "Game of Thrones"
is actually about the
zombie apocalypse,
at least one episode per
season reminds you of that--
so it is out there over,
and over, and over again.
And so what I wanted
to do was I wanted
to write a book that would
help to sort of explain
why it is that we are
so drawn to this story
and also what sorts of
things we learn from it,
because my work as a
critic and a theologian
is largely around
trying to figure out
what is it that we take
away from the things
that we read, or watch,
or listen to, or play.
And we typically consume them
for enjoyment and diversion,
but what often happens is
that we discover that either
consciously or subconsciously--
usually subconsciously--
we're engaging with those
stories in some ways,
watching the decisions
the characters make,
and kind of learning
something in the process.
So here's where
I'd like to begin.
This is a piece from the
first chapter of the book,
and I think it kind
of sets the stage
for what it is that
I was hoping to do
and for the different kinds
of responses that I got.
And then I want to go from
here and talk a little bit
about the zombie as a
metaphor in contemporary life
and some of the different
kind of wisdom points
that we can learn from
the zombie apocalypse.
"My friend Sarah Bird,
an acclaimed novelist
and screenwriter,
recently confessed to me
over pints at a North Campus
pub in our hometown of Austin,
Texas, Greg, I don't get it.
I want to.
I see zombies everywhere,
but the whole thing
seems so bizarre to me.
I understood her.
Despite my passion for
this book and its topic,
I would not describe
myself as a zombie fanatic.
The living dead also seem at
first a strange entertainment
choice to me."
"Like many people
over the age of 18,
I no longer take much
pleasure in being frightened
or in consuming gore
for gore's sake.
I sometimes feel, in fact,
more disturbed than enlightened
by stories of the walking dead.
But as a writer, cultural
critic, and theologian,
it does seem to me that
something important is going on
that I need to understand
and help others understand,
like my friend."
I see zombies everywhere,
and I want to know why."
On that afternoon in Austin,
I looked across the table
at Sarah and summed
up what I had
discovered in two years of
research on two continents.
When humanity seems to be facing
an extinction level event,
the dead get up
and walk around."
That was one of the
most amazing discoveries
that I made in the
course of the research
and writing of this book.
We can go back at least
as far as the Middle Ages.
What we have here is La "Mort
Saint Innocent," the statue
of death that used to stand in
the Cemetery of the Innocents
in Paris, and where it was in
it was surrounded by one
of the best known frescoes
of the rendering of death
coming for every member
of the society,
the danse macabre,
and a whole bunch of human
bones sort of stacked up
to the rafters.
It would have been a
really imposing thing.
Now, the Cemetery of the
Innocents no longer exists.
All the bones that were
there, you may be aware,
are now sort of in the
catacombs underneath Paris,
but imagine sort of
walking into that room
and seeing this figure and
seeing all of these frescoes
around the room of
embodied Death--
Death with a capital D--
reaching out with it's
sort of moldering paw
and grabbing everybody
in society from the pope
down to the lowliest peasant.
One of the things that
was really interesting
as I took a look
at these images,
including La "Mort
Saint Innocent,"
is that they look a little bit
like our zombies in "Walking
Dead" or any of the other sort
of representations of them.
And we find this in art from
the Middle Ages forward.
We find it in art
from the trenches
in World War I. We find it
in art from the Holocaust.
We find it in art from
Hiroshima that there
is this sort of
front and centering
of death and human corpses
at times when people
feel like threats are
moving toward them
from every direction.
And so one of the things
they helped me understand--
the kind of defense mechanism
that writers, storytellers,
artists have used over the
years is simply this idea
that, when things
look really bad,
this is something that seems
to happen in Western culture.
And our zombies, as my
friend says, are bizarre.
They're ridiculous.
They're gory.
At the conversation we had
at Blackstone's bookstore
yesterday in Oxford,
somebody came to me and said,
can you tell me the
scientific mechanism
of how zombies are able to walk?
I said, no, frankly, I
can't do that, but they do.
And they keep walking,
and you have to run.
So this is one of
the first things
that I think is
really important.
Yes, they're bizarre.
Yes, they're gory.
Yes, they're not for
everyone, but they're also
a part of a pattern that we see
in Western culture going back
at least 600 years that
helps us understand
a little bit about what it
means to live in a world
where we live with fear
and we live with threat.
And if you read about
people in the 14th century,
many of the popular
histories of the Middle Ages
that I read in the course of
preparing to write this book--
I was reading about
pandemics, and violence,
and political unrest, and
financial unrest, and drought,
and all of these terrible
things, climactic change,
and I was just like, this is us.
I mean, the only
difference probably
is that we dress a little
better, bathe a little more
often, but this is us.
I mean, we are facing
the same set of problems.
And so maybe it's not
so strange that death
gets up and walks around.
So in these stories where
death gets up and walks around,
one of the things
that we ask is,
how are these things like us
and how are they different?
Most monsters are
somewhat human--
the ones that are
most successful.
If you look at sort of the
classic film monsters--
the mummy, vampires, zombies--
there is a human element.
There is something sort
of recognizable to us,
and yet there is something
different about them
that sets them apart,
and that is what
makes them monstrous to us.
They look like us.
They might even act like us,
and yet they are clearly not us.
And so one of the things that
comes out of the zombie story
is the way that
we can use zombies
as a way of differentiating
ourselves and defining
ourselves, because in many
of the stories of the zombie
apocalypse, that's one
of the front and center
sorts of themes,
going back all the way
to the classic renditions
of George Romero, who
was the originator
of the modern zombie.
In one of his early films,
"The Dawn of the Dead,"
the zombies wander into the
shopping mall and walk around.
And frankly, there's not
a whole lot of difference.
I mean, it's played for humor.
And the elevator
music is-- the muzak
is playing in the
hallways of the mall
as the zombies shamble
from store to store,
and the point that Romero
is kind of sort of making
is that we live
in a culture where
we at least partially define
ourselves by consumption.
That's one of the
things that we do,
but it's hopefully not
the only thing we do.
What the zombie story allows us
also to do is to, as we said,
differentiate ourselves.
In what ways do we
differ from that?
And for all the fact that
we might be sort of caught
in a life where we don't
feel very conscious,
and we do the same thing
sort of over and over again,
and we consume, it's
also possible to think
about what makes us different
from these monsters.
And one of the great examples
from contemporary zombie
literature is the British
film "Shaun of the Dead."
The film title is,
as you've guessed,
a takeoff on "Dawn of the Dead,"
and the main character, Shaun,
is a person who is
sort of caught up
in a life where he does the
same thing day, after day,
after day, after day.
And honestly there is
not that much difference
between him and the zombies that
he's going to encounter later
on in the movie.
So "Shaun of the Dead" is
a sort of obvious play,
not just on the
original Romero film,
but kind of on the theme that
he is stuck in this thing that
is not really life.
And one of the things
out of the three things
that he's written sort of
on his kitchen chalkboard--
go round mum's is one, get
Liz back, sort life out.
Sort life out.
Because Liz tells him in the
first scene of the movie,
I don't want to do this anymore.
We do the same thing
over and over again,
and it just feels
like I am dead.
And so one of the
points, one of the themes
that "Shaun of
the Dead" makes is
that, in an unexamined
life, in a life where
we do the same thing
over and over again,
it can be really hard
to be fully alive.
There is a wonderful
idea that comes
from the Christian
thinker Irenaeus, who
says that the joy of God is
the human being fully alive.
And something very similar
from another wisdom tradition,
the Gautama Buddha talks about,
if something is worth doing,
do it with all your heart.
And yet, we know
from our own lives
that we don't always live
at that 100% human capacity.
I probably have not
achieved it yet today,
but one of the things that
the zombie story gets us to do
is to ask, if we could
live into what we're
capable of as human beings,
if we could be fully alive,
what would that look like?
On the back cover of Robert
Kirkman's first edition
of the graphic novel
of "The Walking Dead,"
there is this wonderful
sentence that I come back
to over and over again when
I'm looking for inspiration
from the zombie apocalypse.
And what Kirkman asked
in that back cover copy--
what he says is, "in a
world where the dead walk,
we have to learn
to finally live."
And that's the crazy,
interesting paradox,
because in these
stories where it
looks like the end
of the world, it also
becomes a way for many of the
characters in these stories
to become sort of what
they're called to be.
And so in the story of
"Shaun of the Dead,"
that's one of the big
things that happens.
During the course of the
story, he becomes a hero.
He becomes somebody
willing to kind of live up
to his fullest extent, willing
to be in a relationship,
willing to really love--
I mean, all of the things
that sort of mark out people
as being fully human.
And by the end of
the story, he's
worked his way through
his kitchen list.
And that is one
of the things that
happens in a lot of these
zombie apocalypse stories.
For those of you that watch
"The Walking Dead," whatever
you think about the current
incarnation of Rick Grimes,
it is a long way from
where we found him
at the beginning of the story.
I mean, he's a small town
deputy who becomes this leader,
and we may not agree with
all the ethical decisions he
makes-- that's something to
talk about in just a moment--
but think about what he has
become because of the zombie
apocalypse.
I mean, it is an
amazing kind of arc
for many of these characters.
Another sort of
similar example would
be the character of Jon
Snow in "Game of Thrones."
Jon Snow is one of
the few characters
to really take seriously the
menace of the White Walkers
and that winter is
actually coming.
And he goes from being
sort of the bastard child
of a noble family
to a leader of men
to a leader of a crusade,
really, of life against death.
And so one of the
paradoxes that happens
in these stories of
the zombie apocalypse--
and it also happens in
other kinds of genres.
it happens in war stories.
It happens in other kinds
of apocalyptic genres--
the end of the world--
is that we get human behavior,
human conflict, human emotion
kind of ratcheted up, because
at the end of the world,
everything matters.
I write these lovely sort
of quiet literary novels
where about 250 pages
in something happens,
and you can't have that
at the end of the world.
Things start happening on
the first page, really.
So that's one of the
really lovely things--
is that the zombie story
and the use of the zombie
gets us to thinking about what
it is that it means to be human
and how we differ from these
sort of stick figure monsters.
The other thing that the
zombies do for us in the zombie
apocalypse story is--
and we probably
can figure this out
because we see this cropping
up at all of these flashpoints
in human history.
They help us to come to
grips with our own mortality,
and they help us
in some way to come
to grips with the idea of
this sort of relentless set
of threats rolling toward us.
And the zombie is
particularly good for this,
because at least one on one,
you have a pretty good chance.
Have you noticed that?
If you have a baseball
bat, crowbar--
there are things lying around
your house that could turn you
into a zombie fighter.
And yes, it would be awful.
And yes, you would have
to clear out enough space
to sleep, and get up, and
do the same thing tomorrow,
but as the novelist and
essayist Chuck Klosterman said,
that actually is what modern
life feels like to me.
Waking up to discover
that I have 400 emails
feels like killing
zombies, because I'm
going to clear those out.
I'm going to file them.
I'm going to respond
to them, and God
knows tomorrow I'm going
to do the same thing again.
And so one of the things that
the zombie apocalypse sort of
gets us to do is to think
about our own lives in a way
that we can go,
yeah, I can do this.
I can settle this.
I can manage this.
And honestly, 400
emails, or having
to unload the dishwasher,
or dropping, the kids
off, or any of those repetitive
tasks that we do over,
and over, and over again that
seem like they are beating us
to death are not nearly as
serious as the zombie horde.
And so one of the things
that many people who
write about zombies say is, this
is a wonderful monster for us
because, at the end
of the day, even
though that it lets us think
about our own problems,
our own problems don't
measure up to this.
It may feel like the
end of the world,
but frankly, it probably
isn't, and that's
kind of a good thing.
So let's think about some of
the wisdom ideas that grow out
of this, because one of the
things that was particularly
interesting for me in
the writing of "Living
with the Living Dead,"
was to think about some
of the particular lessons that
these narratives excel in.
And so I want to talk a
little bit about community,
and I want to talk a
little bit about post-9/11,
post-7/7 ethics, because one
of the things that happens
in connection with the zombie
apocalypse is that most
cultural critics
say that it is--
the popularity of this
story or this trope
is, in some ways,
a direct response
to the number of threats that
we perceive at this moment.
And the sort of
formative thing that we
can do when we think about
this is we can think about 9/11
in September of 2001.
"28 Days Later" came
out a couple of weeks
after the towers
fell in New York,
and the zombie
apocalypse has just
grown in size since that time.
Between a third and a half of
all zombie movies ever made
have come out since
9/11, and so when
we say that there is probably
some sort of connection
with that, obviously, it's
not scientific, except to say,
look at this.
This is one of the biggest
stories in the world,
and there's got to be a reason
that people are so drawn to it.
So let's think about a
couple of the things that
might help account for what
people are getting out of this,
and I want to start
with community,
because one of the things that
the zombie apocalypse is about
is, I think, in some ways,
our current situation.
How do we live in a
world where there are
things that we're afraid of?
Where there are people
that we're afraid of?
Where we wonder and worry about
what life is going to be like?
And what do we do in
response to the people
that we encounter either
locally or outside sort
of our sphere of influence?
In the zombie narratives, there
are two major ways that people
respond to other human beings.
One is to close
themselves off from them--
to, in a sort of contemporary
parlance, build walls.
I will be safe behind
my beautiful wall,
and that is one of the
approaches that people take,
and as we'll see when we talk
about ethics in a second,
it's a natural response to fear.
I will build this wall,
and behind this wall,
I will be safe.
And sort of a corollary
that we could say--
I'm going to respond with
suspicion and possibly
with violence to
anyone that I believe
is going to be a threat.
So that is one way that
we can approach this.
And then the other
way is to think about,
could this person be an ally?
Could I respond to this
person with compassion?
Would my life be improved?
Would my chances of survival
be improved by friendship,
by compassion, by extending
some sort of relationship?
And both of those
things are explored
in the zombie apocalypse story.
Now, as a person who
sort of leans toward hope
as opposed to despair, I
like the second one better,
but I also understand
that first impulse.
And as somebody who is
American and who watched
America's response as we
formulated what we think
of as the war on terror, I
know that that is a response--
that first response is one that
a lot of people thought was
a powerful and appropriate
one, but as we think about
community-- and excuse me for
a second as I mainline some
caffeine--
one of the great zombie
apocalypse stories taking
a look at a community in
the contemporary world
is "Zombieland," and I
don't know if any of you
have seen it.
Yes, one?
Anybody else?
Whether or not you like
zombies, you might enjoy it.
Woody Harrelson is in it--
Jesse Eisenberg, Emma Stone.
I mean, it's got
an amazing cast.
It's smart.
It's funny.
It's a little gory
at the beginning,
and I will just
warn you about that.
You may want to fast forward,
but if you get to the story
itself, what it really
is is a character story.
And this-- by the way,
sort of sidebar this--
one of the really
interesting things
about these stories of
the zombie apocalypse
is that they're not
actually about zombies.
I had the chance to interview
Angela Kang, the writer
and executive producer
of "The Walking Dead,"
and she said, you know, people
think that "The Walking Dead"
is a zombie show.
It's not about zombies.
It's about the human
beings and their response
to a world that's gone crazy.
How do people survive
in a world like that?
That's where the
stories come from,
and in fact, she
was very explicit.
She said, you know, the
monsters on "The Walking Dead"
are not the zombies.
They're human beings, because
that's the interesting part
to explore.
And so what these stories
do is, in the context
of the survival of
their characters,
they let us explore
some of these sort
of universal existential
issues like community.
Where do I stand?
How should I fit
into a world where
there are these sort of
widely different ways
that I can relate
to other people?
So at the opening of
"Zombieland," the character
who's played by Jesse Eisenberg,
who is a student, by the way,
at the University
of Texas in Austin--
there's this nice, little, kind
of local connection to it--
is trying to escape from
Texas, and he is somewhere out
in rural East Texas.
And my god, Texas
just goes on for days.
You probably know that
Texas is the size of France,
and you could drive
across Texas and still--
I mean, it would take a day.
It would take a day and a half.
And so he is apparently trying
to get out of Texas and back
to where he thinks
his family might be,
although it's clear that
he's not very close to them.
And we start off the
movie, and there's
this voiceover from
Columbus, and he
is in a parking lot
in a gas station.
And he says, that's
me down there.
And he says, you might
find it surprising
that I've survived this
long, you know, what
with my different kind of
quirks and my irritable bowel
syndrome, but I think
the reason that I've
made it this far is that I never
really had much use for people.
Even before people
were zombies, I
treated them like
they were zombies.
And that's an important
thing, because we'll come back
to that in just a second.
Basically, what he is saying
is he has lived this long
because he doesn't have to
rely on anybody but himself,
and he's created a set of rules.
If you want to check
out the internet meme,
it would be Zombieland rules.
And they are rules like
cardio, which is immediately
illustrated for us when he is
chased by first one, then two,
and then three zombies
around the parking lot
as he's trying to fuel his car.
Another of the rules that would
be pretty important if you were
trying to live alone in the
world of the zombie apocalypse
is watch out for bathrooms.
I mean, that is the
last place where
you want to be approached
by a zombie, right?
And then the third
one, which becomes
important at the
end of the story--
and it makes sense if
you're thinking about things
from that initial idea of how we
relate to other human beings--
but the third rule
that I want to mention
to you that's explored at
the outset of "Zombieland" is
don't be a hero.
Don't be a hero.
And we know this from
other narratives.
One of my favorite
American films,
"Casablanca," the Humphrey
Bogart character, Rick,
says I stick my
neck out for nobody.
And that is a way of making
your way in this world, right?
And it's gotten him this far.
He's at least
halfway out of Texas,
and that's halfway
across France.
Don't be a hero.
And so when he meets some
other survivors along the way,
his initial response
to them is not
that compassionate, welcoming,
hospitality sort of.
Response it's the sort of
hermeneutic of suspicion.
I'm going to read everything
you do with the idea
that you may want to
hurt me or that you
may want to take what
I have, and that's
a very typical thing that we
find in the zombie apocalypse,
as we'll see in a second.
And so he meets the Woody
Harrelson character,
and sort of against their best
judgment they kind of drive
on together.
And then they meet these
two sisters, who immediately
reward their trust by stealing
their car, and, in fact,
steal their car more than
once in this movie, which
is kind of an interesting
thing, and it sort of reminds us
that there are guidelines and
a lot of wisdom traditions
about how we live together,
because human beings, as I was
telling my son the other
day, disappoint each other
on a pretty regular basis.
And so you have to
forgive each other
if you're going to go on being
in relationship with them,
but the really important
point of "Zombieland"
is that we get to the
third act of the movie,
and Columbus decides
that he is going
to set aside some
of his usual rules
because he's started to
develop relationships
with these people.
He's started to care about them.
He realized that
they care about him
and that life is actually
better-- not just
pragmatically better in that
you've got another set of eyes
to watch for zombies,
but better in the sense
that we were talking about
earlier and the idea of being
fully realized human beings.
We are better with each other
than we are by ourselves.
Desmond Tutu talks
about this concept.
He calls Ubuntu, which is a
southern African concept that
is really sort of
alien to Americans
who have this idea of
individuality and pulling
yourself up by
your own bootstrap,
but the idea behind
Ubuntu is that we
are formed by each other.
Literally it's translated
I am because we are,
and it's an idea about
how important community
can be in making us the people
that we're called to be,
in supporting us, and
challenging us, and pushing us.
And what we find in
"Zombieland" is this idea
that Columbus has actually
become a better person--
not just a safer person,
but a better person
because he's been involved
with these people.
And so he sees these
sisters in danger
toward the end of
the movie, and he
changes the "Zombieland" rules.
Don't be a hero gets
thrown out the window.
The new rule, he
says, is be a hero.
And at the end of
the movie, there
is this wonderful
kind of voiceover
that parallels the one
at the beginning-- the
that's me down there by myself.
He's like, look at that guy
in that truck over there.
Look at those girls.
They're the closest thing
I've ever had to family.
And the last words of the
movie are really lovely,
because they tie us back
into the whole idea of how
the zombie apocalypse
can teach us.
What Columbus says at
the very end of the movie
and we fade out is, if you
don't have other people,
you might as well be a zombie.
And we see this in
other places, as well.
We can see it in
"Game of Thrones."
we can see it in
"The Walking Dead."
We can see it in other films.
We can see it novels
and graphic novels.
We can even see it
in such simple things
as the zombie modules in
first person shooters, where
you're part of a team and you
can decide whether to resurrect
somebody or not.
I've had endless discussions
with my 19 year old son about
whether that's a good
game tactic or not.
And I'm like, who cares if
it's a good game tactic?
Be a good person.
Go get them up.
But dad, that
doesn't make sense.
I don't care.
We were arguing when
I put him on the bus
to Brussels a while ago.
So that's the first thing that
I think is really important.
The zombie apocalypse allows us
to explore this question of how
we think about
community in a world
where we wrestle
with fear and menace
coming at us from lots
of different directions.
And again, as we said, those
two responses are there.
We can see the second
response in some places,
and it's an exciting and
really energizing response,
because it's, as we said, this
way that we can think about
being fully human, but the first
response makes sense to us,
too, because it's a response
that we've seen lived out
in our own post-9/11 reality.
And so in the last couple of
minutes of my time talking
with you, I want to
talk a little bit
about some of the ethics
of the zombie apocalypse
and some of the ways
that it sort of makes
us reflect on the world that we
live in now and our responses
to threat and menace.
One of the most important
tales of the zombie apocalypse
is not actually a story
with zombies in it.
There is a novel by the great
American author Cormac McCarthy
called "The Road,"
and there was a film
that was made of this, as well.
And I was taken to task by a
zombie journal for including it
in my book because they
were angry because there are
no actual zombies, but if
you have not read the book,
then I will just sort
of explain to you.
It's a post apocalyptic
future in which there
are a few human survivors, and
many of the remaining survivors
are eating the other
survivors, so it kind of
feels zombie-ish to me.
And it's the same kinds of
ethical questions and dilemmas
that get explored in
this book in a very
literary and beautiful way.
The two main characters the
book are a father and a son.
The man and the boy is
how they're described.
Their names are
never given, and they
are trying to get to
the sea for reasons
that we don't really know.
There's no food.
All the vegetation is dead.
This is a horrible, horrible
world that they're living in.
And when they encounter
people along the way,
the father treats each of those
people as a potential threat,
and so that's that
first reaction
that we were talking about
to the sort of reaction
of suspicion and fear.
And it's certainly
justified, because there
is a horrific
scene in "The Road"
where the father and son go down
into a cellar looking for food
and find a secret trap door.
And they go down into the trap
door underneath the cellar,
and they discover the
people living in that house
are keeping human beings chained
up in that larder for food.
They are eating them
a limb at a time.
I mean, it's one of the
most horrible visions
of hell on earth that
you could ever imagine.
And they flee that house.
They just manage to get away
as the owners of the house
come back, and so it's very
clear that this is a really
terrible world, and it's OK to
be afraid in a world like this,
but one of the things that
the story keeps coming back to
is the son keeps asking his
father, are we the good guys?
So they have these
conversations,
and the son asks
the father things
like, we would never
eat anybody, right?
No, we would never eat anybody,
and I know that sounds funny,
but in a sort of metaphorical
way, it's OK for us
to ask that question.
We would never eat anybody.
And there's actually this
sort of ongoing conversation
that they have about how
they are carrying the light.
They are the good guys.
I mean, they've got to stay
alive because they're carrying
the light, but the little boy
observes that, on their journey
to the sea--
they walk past a dog,
and a little boy,
and an old man who's
been struck by lightning.
And every time they encounter
somebody on the road
the son says,
can't we help them?
And the father
says, no, we can't.
And those of us who are
parents or those of us who
are in charge of somebody
understand that impulse,
because the father is saying
I am responsible for you,
and if we give this person
food or if we stop and help
this person and they are a
decoy and we get captured--
I mean, the chances of
something bad happening
are too high for
us to be generous.
And yet the boy keeps
asking with every encounter,
can't we help them?
Can't we help them?
And finally they get toward
the end of the story,
and I will leave the very last
part of the novel untouched,
spoiler free, because it is
one of the very few slightly
hopeful moments in the
oeuvre of Cormac McCarthy,
and if you're actually
going to read this novel,
I don't want to
spoil it for you.
But the boy says
to his father, you
say that we are the
good guys and that we're
carrying the light, but we
don't ever do anything good.
We don't ever help anyone.
And it's kind of
a shattering out
of the mouths of
babes kind of moment,
because for those
of us as readers
who have identified really
strongly with the father
and understood the
decisions he makes,
it suddenly places us in that
stark moment where we have
to think about, oh, I get that.
Pragmatically, he has made
really good decisions,
but what do I do with
what the son is asking?
How can we be the good guys
if we never do a good thing?
Now, that does not
mean, by the way,
that there is a
simple answer to this,
because that's the thing
about the ethics of the zombie
apocalypse and the ethics
of the post-9/11 world.
The decisions are not easy.
And I said in Oxford
yesterday I think of myself
as a Christian pacifist, but
I remember a passage of one
of Bono's interviews
where he said,
I am a Christian
pacifist, and if somebody
breaks into my house and
goes after my family,
I will stop being a
Christian pacifist
so fast it will
make your head spin,
because one of
the things that we
have to wrestle with
in the real world
is, how do we live out
our ethical beliefs?
There is a line in Harry
Potter where Dumbledore
asks whether the
people listening will
be able to do the
thing that is right
or the thing that is easy.
And again, there's
not an easy solution.
I'm not advocating for
one over the other,
and I can say that
I would be one
of those Christian
pacifists who stopped
being Christian pacifist so
quick it would make your head
spin, but these stories
do make us think.
They make us ask questions.
They make us wonder if
we're doing the right thing
or even what the
right thing might be.
And I that's one of the great
services of them for us.
So let me call sort of
a halt to the formal
I want to talk to
you about this book
and what I discovered
section, and I think
we've got time for
some questions,
and I hope you will ask some.
I mean, I can talk a little
bit more if we need to,
but I would really
love to know what
you would like to hear about
and if there are questions
or if there are
particular zombie texts
that you're drawn
to or wonder about.
So, anybody?
Yes, right here in front.
AUDIENCE: I like this idea that
you've drawn from this picture.
Thanks.
I like this idea you've
drawn from this picture
from a museum like the image of
death you see on so many like--
inside so many churches and so
many places to the zombies now
and how it's kind of a guiding
light, in a way, about how
we can live our lives, but
also the image of death
as current society
sort of pictures it.
So I just wonder if you've
given any thought to where
that might go in the future.
So we have zombies now just
like the image of death,
I guess, was so prominent at
one point, which now people
would just laugh at.
I wonder if you'd given any
thought to where it could go.
GREG GARRETT: Well, in the
first chapter that I just
read to you from--
I was hoping there were
going to be engineers here,
because I found a mathematical
study where somebody used
a model based on epidemiology--
sort of the spread
of an epidemic--
to think about how
much longer the zombie
apocalypse is going
to be a powerful kind
of pervasive story for us.
And in the mathematical
model that they set out,
they were saying
this is probably
going to be one of our
most prominent stories
for the next 30 or 40 years.
Now, beyond that,
it's hard to say.
One of the things that I
think is really interesting
is that, as you look at
the different iterations
in different historical
periods, they
have found new ways
to use the old images.
So if we say that,
in some sense,
our zombies are a rebooting
of capital D Death--
and I'll be honest.
There are some pictures,
including this amazing picture
from Bruegel, where there is
an army of the dead sweeping
across the landscape, and
it looks like something out
of "The Walking Dead."
It just looks like, oh my
god, here they come, and it's
the end of everything,
but I think probably what
we're going to see
is, in the future,
that there will be some new
kind of iteration of this that's
appropriate for whatever
kinds of storytelling
they have in that era.
So 1968 when "Night of
the Living Dead" came out
was one of the most horrific
years in American history,
and it sort of makes
sense that, instead
of being a poster, or
a stained glass image,
or a bronze statue, it would
be a movie, because that,
for Americans in 1968,
was the most powerful
and the most consumed
form of storytelling.
So I think we'll probably
see new versions of this,
and we probably don't
know what that's
going to look like
until we get there,
but I mean, judging
from the last 600 years,
there's going to be
some element of this
in just whatever crazy virtual
reality storytelling we
have 100 years down the road.
AUDIENCE: Brought
to you by Google.
GREG GARRETT: Yeah, brought
to you by Google, exactly.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, what
was the backdrop to 1968?
Was that civil rights?
GREG GARRETT: Yeah, 1968--
for those of you that are
not American history buffs,
it's Vietnam War, assassinations
of Martin Luther King
and Robert Kennedy, changes
in cultural and sexual mores,
political unrest,
I mean, basically
the whole sort of census
that we just talked about
with the Middle Ages and
that we could sort of talk
about in terms of our modern
sort of set of challenges.
It's just sort of one
of those crazy things
where George Romero
didn't know that 1968
was going to be one of the
worst years in American history
any more than the makers
of "28 Days Later"
knew that 9/11 was
going to happen
or U2 knew that they needed to
make an album that would make
people feel better
about 9/11 happening,
but that seems to be the
sort of strange conjunction
that we find, that we say
that artists kind of tap
in, in some way, to the
zeitgeist of a particular time
and maybe are even ahead of
their time in anticipating.
And it's kind of remarkable
when you think about them.
AUDIENCE: I was just going to
ask-- the zombies, obviously,
they are people who've died.
They come back to life, but they
don't just come back to life
and just start walking
around aimlessly.
They come back to life and
then turn on the humans
that they've been
with and oftentimes
in a lot of recent
popular stuff they
tend to turn on
the people who are
closest to them first of all.
Do you think that that is
just to emphasize the fear
and therefore sort of
compound these themes
that you were talking
about earlier,
or do you think there might
be something more deep seated
associated?
GREG GARRETT: I think that's
a nice reading, actually.
The remake of "Dawn of
the Dead," which is--
the original one appeared in
the '80s, and this other one is
post-9/11, but the remake--
at the beginning of the film,
one of the main characters
is attacked by the little
girl who lives across the hall
and by her boyfriend, both of
whom have just become zombies.
And so I think a part of
it may be that sort of fear
of those who are closest to us.
And if you go back to the 1968
"Night of the Living Dead,"
maybe the most horrific
image from that film--
there's a little girl
who turns into a zombie,
kills her father--
or eats her father, kills
her mother, and "Variety,"
the great sort of trade
magazine of American film,
said this is the most
reprehensible movie
making that has ever been.
The producers and
director of this film
should be ashamed of themselves
for what they've done.
I mean, it was shocking.
It's still shocking
today, because we
think the people
that we're closest to
are the people with whom
we should feel safest,
but a lot of times in the zombie
stories, as you point out,
they are the first
people to be turned on.
And I guess what
that does-- if we
want to think about taking I
am afraid of Syrian refugees,
or I am afraid of the
opposing political party,
or I am afraid of walking out
my door and being blown up,
but it also brings that
down to a domestic level.
And a lot of horror
films do that, as well.
So there's often a
societal level of fear
that's dealt with in horror
films and a very personal kind
of thing, which is, I think,
one of the things that
does make it so scary.
I mean, that's a
great observation.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
You mentioned before
that "The Walking Dead"
is one of the most popular
shows around, and at its heart,
it's quite a cynical
show in terms of how it
deals with humans and zombies.
And in recent
years, there's been
an influx of new material
that sort of humanizes zombies
in a different way between
"The Girl With All the Gifts,"
and "Warm Bodies,
"iZombie," and so on.
To what do you attribute the
success of "The Walking Dead,"
whereas these sort
of softer shows
struggle to build or
maintain an audience?
GREG GARRETT: I know.
I mean, that's a really
interesting question.
I think part of it is
that "The Walking Dead" is
sort of straight down the
middle of the fairway in terms
of the zombie narrative.
And a show like "iZombie,"
as interesting and really
human as it can be,
for whatever reason,
doesn't have the same kind of
maybe mythic quality to it.
And I think also
probably it lacks, just
in terms of narrative, that
really compelling survival
story that we find in "Walking
Dead," or "28 Days Later,"
or any of the sort
of-- are these people
that we've come to care
about going to last
to the end of the story?
So I think maybe that's
it in narrative terms.
I wonder if those stories
where we humanize the zombies
confuse us a little bit, too,
because we were saying earlier
that it's kind of nice
to be able to look
and kind of draw
some distinctions,
but I know that many of the
stories where zombies are given
agency and intelligence
are really difficult,
because they're kind
of challenging for us.
And I think particularly--
I hope that some of
you will have a chance
to encounter this--
there is a best
selling comic series
in the States called
"Marvel Zombies,"
and in this series
of graphic novels,
those iconic Marvel
characters like Spider-Man,
and Iron Man, and all of the
other sort of iconic heroes
are afflicted by a zombie virus,
and they become these consuming
monsters.
And for most of them, it's just
like, OK, they sort of give
themselves over
to the dark side,
but a couple of them, including
the Spider-Man character
in this series, still have
enough kind of sentience to go,
this is horrible.
I can't believe
what we've become.
And when I think about
all of the zombie stories
that I read, or
looked at, or watched,
the "Marvel Zombies"
story is one of the ones
that keeps me up at night.
And I think part of
it is just that it's
kind of nice to sort of
feel good guy/bad guy,
and not have to deal with that
really powerful gray area,
but that's a lovely question.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Do you
touch in the book
on the influence of
Michael Jackson and John
Landis [INAUDIBLE]?
GREG GARRETT: Not an awful
lot, except to sort of think
about that as a
really good example,
because what we're talking
about here, of course,
is the "Thriller" video,
which, at the time it was made,
was the most expensive
music video ever made.
And it's a long sort of epic.
AUDIENCE: It was the first
of its kind, actually.
GREG GARRETT: Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely.
And I think what's sort
of interesting about that
is that it was clear that,
for John Landis and Michael
Jackson, they knew
that people would
be familiar enough
with this story
that they didn't have to do a
whole lot to sort of explain
it.
It's just like, OK,
this is a music video,
and there are zombies,
and we kind of
know what this all means because
we've seen this story before.
And so I don't talk an
awful lot about that,
but I think one
of the fun things
about that is just
sort of thinking
about that in terms of the kind
of popularity of the narrative.
Good.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
When you were writing
the book, did you
come across other sort of
creatures, monsters that just
appeared as you were
researching zombies, and how
did you deal with that?
Did you think, oh,
this is another book,
or I'll deal with
vampires later?
And do you think that there are
different times and places that
suit different types
of monsters better?
So I think, thinking
about vampire stories,
they tend to be
more love stories.
Zombies don't touch so
much on love stories.
GREG GARRETT: That actually
is a lovely question.
This book is a sequel to my
first book for Oxford, which
is a book called
"Entertaining Judgment," which
is about narratives
of life after death,
and there was a chapter in
that book on the undead.
And it got bigger, and bigger,
and bigger, and bigger.
It was 100 pages.
It was past 100 pages
for a 300 page book,
and it became very clear
that this was something
that I couldn't really deal
with in the scope of a book
and which I also wanted
to talk about people's
conceptions of what
happens to us when we die.
So vampires and ghosts are maybe
the other two really pervasive
forms of the undead, and they do
kind of reflect different hopes
and fears.
And the vampire story,
as you were saying,
is often tied to a love story.
And the vampire is, at
least in some appearances,
it looks like the things
that we seem to want most--
eternal life, eternal youth--
but in most of the sort of
classic Bram Stoker version
vampire stories, there
is a very real cost
to be paid for those
really cool things.
So when you see the
representation of Dracula,
say, in a down moment
when nobody's looking
and you realize that he's
this hideous old man,
or when you think
about what you have
to do to earn eternal
life and eternal youth,
and you've got to be
a monster devouring,
drinking blood for the rest
of your eternal life, that's
super scary.
The ghost thing is kind of fun,
because in a lot of stories,
it ties into the kind of
mega narrative of purgatory.
And in many of our
stories of ghosts,
it's about I have
this sort of phase
that I've got to go
through or something
that I've got to
accomplish before I
move on to what's next.
So there's the Patrick
Swayze/Demi Moore film "Ghost"
in which, once he's done the
thing that he's there to do,
he can move on.
And for many people,
"The Sixth Sense"
is one of the great ghost
stories of all time,
and it's really sort of
straight up purgatory.
It's like, I've got this time
that I've got to do this thing,
and when it's done, I'm going
to go on to whatever's next.
So I think the ghost
story a lot of times
can be a really
human story for us,
because we all have this idea
that there are phases that we
go through in our
lives-- what I found
about purgatory in the
last book was that it's
kind of the narrative
that we come back to
over and over again.
Something terrible happens in
the first act of every story,
and it gets more complicated,
and it gets resolved,
and the story ends.
And so that purgatory
sort of meta narrative
is actually kind of the
pattern for every great story.
And some of those ghost stories
are just really good examples
of that because there's the
supernatural after death
element of it that ties it
to the purgatory story even
stronger.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
very much, Greg.
That was brilliant.
GREG GARRETT: You
are so welcome.
[APPLAUSE]